une des choses que je une des choses que
je regrette le plus dans ma vie c'est
d'abord pris part à une brigade anti gay
quand j'étais ado j'étais alors un
centre de formation pour devenir joueur
de football professionnel et je suis
parti avec quelques amis dans un bois où
des homos se rencontrer
le but était de leur faire peur de les
intimider mais le but était surtout pour
moi de vraiment tout faire pour qu'on ne
m'associe pas à cette communauté du haut
de mes 16 ans chassé des homos en
quelque sorte de ce bois était bien la
preuve que je n'en était pas un
et a presque voilà vingt ans plus tard
en juin dernier j'ai fait la couverture
de ce magazine
donc pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
têtus et le magazine guînes numéro un en
france
donc comme vous pouvez l'imaginer il ya
pas mal de chemin qui a été parcouru
depuis et donc moi je suis issu de
milieux très homophobe je viens d'une
cité du sud de la france je suis
musulman et j'ai baigné toute ma vie
dans le monde du football et on va dire
que c'est pas d environnement très
propice à la découverte de son
homosexualité et encore moins à son
acceptation que ce soit avec mes coaches
en famille ou avec les années être gay
n'était jamais admissibles
j'étais en quelque sorte on va dire
prédestiné à devenir anomaux honte
malheureux enfin tous les ingrédients
vraiment été réunis dans la vie pour que
je vive caché dans la honte mais on va
dire que j'ai réussi tant bien que mal à
changer ma trajectoire de vie était
quand même devant vous un garçon
épanouie qui se présentent aujourd'hui
donc moi je m'appelle wissem ben
belgacem j'ai sorti le 5 mai 2021 livre
qui s'intitule adjoint honte dans lequel
je raconte mon histoire
j'y parle d'ascension sociale j'y parle
de vivre ensemble et j'y parle beaucoup
aussi de cette homophobie qui m'a forcé
à faire un choix en fait entre ma
carrière sportive et mon épanouissement
personnel et si j'ai écrit ce livre et
si j'ai fait le choix de faire cette
conférence aujourd'hui c'est parce que
j'aimerais qu'il n'y ait plus jamais
aucun gamin qui se retrouve à devoir
renoncer à ses rêves pour des raisons
injuste
est ce que vous connaissez le nombre de
footballeurs
gays qui a pu concilier sa carrière
sportive et vivre sa sexualité librement
je vous affiche le numéro à l'écran
c'est zéro
c'est zéro c zéro et c'est très triste
parce que ben voilà le football comme
tous les sports on a le droit de vivre
de sa passion quelle que soit sa
sexualité et d'ailleurs les récents jeux
olympiques de tokyo nous ont confirmé
l'évidence ans les athlètes aux mots
sont aussi performants que les athlètes
et héros parce que bien évidemment une
orientation sexuelle influence en rien
sur le patrimoine génétique d'un
individu
le site à watts pause nous a dit qu'il y
avait plus de 180 athlètes appartenant à
la communauté lgbt plus à rio et ça
c'est trois fois plus
pardon à tokyo et ça c'est trois fois
plus qu'à rio du coup et donc ses stats
elle nous dit pas que en l'espace de
quatre ans le nombre de personnes gay
sur terre a triplé 1 mais ça nous montre
juste à quel point le nombre de
personnes vivent dans la honte et vivent
cachés et grands et moi ça ça m'étonne
pas du tout parce qu'à titre personnel
ma carrière de footballeur je ne saurai
jamais ce qu'elles auraient pu être
parce que j'ai saboté quand j'avais 20
ans j'étais épuisée j'étais consumer et
1 j'en pouvais plus en fait imaginer ça
faisait plus de dix ans que je faisais
semblant d'essayer de choper des filles
à chaque fois que j'étais avec mes
coéquipiers plus de dix ans
que je mentais à tout le monde plus de
dix ans que j'ai envoyé des textos de
mon premier téléphone sur mon deuxième
téléphone pour que ma famille puisse
lire les textos du coup des textos deux
filles et continuent à penser que
j'étais hétéro
et ça ça prend énormément énormément
d'énergie comme vous pouvez l'imaginer
dans la dans la construction d'un
individu c'est
c'était juste épuisant au fait c'était
juste épuisant
c'était juste et plus un puits et le
foot ça fait partie de ces sports où
c'est tellement compétitif que du coup
si on n'est pas à 100%
ça devient extrêmement dur du coup de
réussir à percer de réussir à marseille
et dans nos sociétés pseudo égalitaire
que ce soit notre couleur de peau notre
origine sociale ou je sais pas notre
religion ça ne devrait jamais avoir un
impact quelconque que ce soit positif ou
négatif sur nos accomplissements ce
serait trop injuste
mais si on se parle sincèrement vous et
moi aujourd'hui est ce qu'on peut dire à
un enfant qui naît en france en étant
d'arabes noir ou gay qu'il sera sur un
pied d'égalité avec le reste de la
population
qu'il aura les mêmes opportunités les
mêmes absences de barrières je ne pense
pas sincèrement je pense pas et pour
l'avoir vécu je vous confirme que non et
vous savez les plus grandes barrières se
sont pas forcément celles dont on entend
souvent parler dans les médias ou autres
à savoir trouver un appartement où
trouver un job bon ben alors ça on toute
façon on sait très bien que c'est plus
difficile pour certains que pour
d'autres mais les barrières les plus
difficiles à franchir pour moi sont les
barrières psychologiques
à titre personnel ce qui m'a le plus
traîner dans ma vie dans tout ce que
j'ai voulu entreprendre ça a toujours
été le regard que la société et mes
communautés porte sur ma sexualité
ça ça a été l'obstacle de ma vie et vous
savez dans la vie il ya des choses qu'on
choisit et des choses qu'on ne choisit
pas par exemple
j'ai choisi cette tenue pour monter sur
scène aujourd'hui ça peut plaire ou pas
c'est discutable y'a pas de soucis mais
comment peut-on reprocher à quelqu'un
quelque chose qu'il ou elle n'a jamais
choisi on choisit pas la couleur de ses
yeux on choisit pas sa couleur de peau
il faut que tout le monde entende de
manière très claire on ne choisit pas
non plus son orientation sexuelle donc
comment peut-on leur reprocher à
quelqu'un
et vous savez j'ai envie d'aller encore
plus loin avec vous aujourd'hui quand
bien même ce serait un choix où est le
problème à ce qu'un homme choisissent un
homme et une femme une femme non mais
franchement en 2021 n'y a pas des choses
plus préoccupantes sur terre dont on
pourrait s'occuper
c'est quand même incroyable autre chose
qu'on ne choisit pas ses patients et moi
par exemple je suis tombé amoureux du
foot on m'a jamais forcée à quoi que ce
soit je n'avais pas le père où les
grands frères à me dire vasilis aiment
le foot le foot le foot c'est comme ça
il ya des gens qui ont des passions pour
les collections d'argenterie pour les
oiseaux pour les tatouages c'est comme
ça on n'explique pas
mais dans la construction d'un individu
il n'y a rien de pire entre
l'incompatibilité entre deux choses
qu'on n'a jamais choisi moi en
l'occurrence c'était le football est mon
homosexualité je ne pouvais et tendre ni
l'un ni l'autre et les deux semblaient
irréconciliables
et c'est pas faute d'avoir essayé parce
que j'ai littéralement tout tenté pour
changer ma sexualité parce que je ne
voulais pas que sympa que de manière
négative ma carrière de footballeur donc
j'ai pratiquer l'abstinence j'ai prié
très très fort je sortis avec des filles
j'ai consulté plus d'une dizaine de psy
mais rien n'y a fait je me suis juste
épuisé dans une quête vaine plus d'une
dizaine d'années de ce que j'appelle
dans mon livre une quête des terreaux
sexualisation
et vous savez le football c'est marrant
parce que c'est assez paradoxal comme
sport dans le sens où c'est le sport le
plus fédérateur ça une capacité à
rassembler les gens c'est phénoménal
lors de grands événements comme la coupe
du monde moi je trouve ça magnifique
tous ces gens dans les stalles derrière
leur écran la com comme beaucoup je
trouve ça beau et émouvant mais ce qu'on
occulte souvent de dire c'est que le
football c'est aussi le sport qui exclut
le plus
c'est un sport où globalement on veut
rester entre sommes bien évidemment
hétéro et cette domination que j'appelle
domination masculine a fait qu'on a mis
beaucoup de temps par exemple à tolérer
les femmes dans les stades en tant que
supportrice ou alors allez trouver à
fait légitime pour qu'elle puisse
arbitrer des matchs de football masculin
et ça une fois de plus je trouve pas que
ce soit normal
c'est un petit peu un wayne une sorte de
non sens et vous savez moi enfin moi par
ailleurs aussi autre chose que j'ai pu
constater un dans ma carrière de
footballeur c'est que la confusion est
tellement grande entre masculinité et
hétérosexualité il ya tellement de
joueurs de coach de dirigeants et même
de commentateurs sportifs qui ont une
vision erronée de la masculinité
et du coup sûr le spectre de celle-ci ce
qu'on retrouve tout en bas ce sont les
hommes gais deux hommes qui s'aiment et
qui s'embrassent ça leur paraît
inconcevable et ça c'est dû en grande
partie à la valorisation et à la
glorification exacerbée du football pour
les comportements dits masculins
et dans leur tête l'équation semble très
simple être gay signifie être féminin
est donc faible parce que la racine de
la misogynie
et de l'homophobie est la même
et je pense que les médias ont une
grande part de responsabilité aussi sur
ses schémas de pensée parce que pendant
très longtemps on nous a montré que ce
soit en tant que chroniqueur dans des
émissions ou des télé réalités des
personnes gays avec une part de féminité
très prononcé et alors ça c'est génial
dans un premier temps parce que ça nous
a permis de visibiliser une communauté
et joe seul fait qu'on en avait besoin
mais le problème c'est que des homos qui
comme moi ne savaient déjà qu'ils
n'étaient pas hétéro et ne se
reconnaissaient pas forcément dans les
personnes gay concon médiatisé et moi
j'ai pendant longtemps pensé être un peu
une anomalie un bug dans la matrice je
me dis matin n'était pas hétéro mettait
pas non plus gai mais qu'est ce que t'es
du coup il m'a fallu du temps des
lectures des rencontres pour comprendre
que oui en fait il est possible d'être à
la fois masculin est homosexuel mais
imaginez
vous êtes dans un vestiaire de foot et
si un coéquipier veut se moquer d'un
autre joueur il va se mettre à dandiner
de manière féminine et tout le vestiaire
rigolera à l'unisson ou alors imaginez
vous êtes à la mi-temps d'un match hyper
important votre coach quand il n'est pas
content et jim et mais bougez
vous la jouer comme des
ou alors vous avez 16 ans comme moi j'ai
pu les avoir et vous allez voir votre
équipe de football préférée vous poser
dans le stade tranquille vous avez
commandé free de coca nous allons donc
le match démarre et là pendant 90
minutes vous entendez des dizaines de
milliers de personnes chanter à
l'unisson des chants homophobes
vous ajoutez à cela l'absence totale de
parole inclusive dans le sport et du
coup vous comprenez facilement pourquoi
j'ai dû vivre une vie de mensonges
pourquoi aucun moment je me suis dit
bête que je vais faire mon coming out
parce que moi non seulement je jouer au
football mais je devais jouer à l'hétéro
je devais jouer aux machos et je devais
jouer à l'homophobe
ça peut faire un peu beaucoup
ça peut faire un peu beaucoup pour un
adolescent
mais du coup s'il ya bien un sujet sur
lequel je peux sans problème me déclaré
un expert devant vous aujourd'hui c'est
la honte on se connaît très très bien et
les moins lente pour grandir de manière
exponentielle là on a besoin de deux
ingrédients principalement le silence et
le jugement le silence c'est le fait de
ne pouvoir
communiquer sur son problème à personne
donc on parle pas et le jugement c'est
le fait d'entendre tous les jours des
des messages des mots dégradant
humiliant négatif sur ce sujet qu'on
garde enfouis et vous savez la honte
elle vous prend beaucoup d'énergie elle
vous empêche de vous construire
elle vous consumera de l'intérieur est
en fait elle grandit à mesure qu'elle
vous détruit et dans le processus
de construction d'un individu la notion
de validation cevital est ce que
j'entends par validation sait recevoir
l'amour les compliments de son entourage
donc moi par exemple quand mes potes me
disais à wiesen vous allez trop bien
ensemble avec ta copine franchement
bravo et moi je savais que ce pseudo
couple était un peu une mascarade donc
je pouvais pas recevoir le compliment à
sa juste valeur pareil pour ma propre
mère quand elle me disait mon fils je
t'aime mais je savais qu'elle disait je
t'aime aux huit scènes qu'elle pensait
hétéro donc moi je pouvais pas vous
recevoir son amour mais limite qu'ils
préféraient klm une image de moi plutôt
que connaître le vrai wissem et ça ça
détruit ça ça empêche de se construire
et on y perd tous en fait moi
vous tout le monde et je vais tenter de
vous expliquer pourquoi
à travers un exemple
80 ans
ceux qui sont pas au courant de 81 ans
c'est l'espérance de vie moyenne d'un
français qui n'est aujourd'hui
80 ans et 29 mille jours c'est un peu
plus de 700 milliards sept cent mille
heures sur terre pour créer pour
produire pour inventer pour détruire
pour tomber pour se relever et pour
apporter à la société
et si je vous donne une analogie
intéressante c'est simple un homme blanc
hétérosexuel valide en 80 ans va
parcourir disons 10 mille kilomètres
tous les autres profils iront moins loin
tellement moins loin plié sous les
discriminations et les exclusions que
nous la société leur mettre sur le dos
et ça c'est même s'il allait plus ou
autant de potentiel
et le problème c'est que tous ces
coureurs des avantages et ils
parcoureront pas la distance qu'ils
étaient censés parcourir et on y perd
tous parce que du coup combien de films
ne verront jamais le jour à cause du
poids de la honte que certaines
communautés m sur certains individus
combien de livres ne seront jamais écrit
combien de vaccins ne seront jamais
inventé combien d'athlètes lgbt ne
monteront jamais sur un podium à des
jeux olympiques parce qu'ils auront eu
tellement honte d'eux qu'ils sont dans
leur sport qui se seront détournés
désirons faire autre chose et pour moi
la honte elle est là pour moi la honte
devrait être sur ces personnes qui mit
un singe quand un joueur noir et sur un
terrain de foot à tous ceux qui pensent
qu'une femme vaut un peu moins qu'un
homme
et à tous ceux qui pensent que ben un
footballeur gay n'a rien à faire dans le
football et du coup ils les empêchent de
vivre leur carrière sereinement
donc en fait à la question comment se
construit ton contre ces communautés moi
je vous dirais qu'en fait on ne se
construit pas contre ces communautés au
plus tôt se construit une malle
est ce que je sais pas moi un noir sera
épanouie dans un environnement blanc est
raciste
clairement pas est ce qu'une musulmane
serait heureuse dans une société qui
sous couvert de laïcité déblatère de
l'islamophobie à tout va non et est ce
qu'un joueur de foot aujourd'hui dans le
niveau d'homophobie actuelle dans ce
sport là en france pourra vivre une
carrière sereinement mais une fois de
plus la réponse est non
alors est ce qu'il existe des outils que
ces personnes-là pourrait éventuellement
utilisés pour faire face à tant
d'adversité mais j'ai bien peur qu une
fois de plus la conclusion soit non et
je trouverais en fait trop injuste qu'on
demande à ces personnes de trouver un
moyen de faire face à un environnement
aussi hostile
pour moi le la solution viendra de nous
la solution viendra de vous mais vous
qui êtes parent
s'accoutrer quoi de dire à votre fils
alors tu as une amoureuse ou un amoureux
ces trois mots en plus ça peut leur
changer la vie
toi le fan de foot ça changerait quoi de
bannir les chants homophobes
franchement la langue française est si
riche n'y aurait aucun problème à
trouver des champs qui ne blessent et
n'exclut personne
mais ces choses encore faut-il en avoir
conscience et encore faut-il en avoir
envie d'agir sur cette thématique là
et moi je pense qu à une hypocrisie
qu'il faut arrêter aussi c'est de
s'indigner seulement contre les
discriminations qui nous concerne moi ça
j'en peux plus en fait pour moi le salut
viendra quand toutes les voix
s'élèveront contre toutes les formes de
discrimination quelle qu'elle soit on
fait tous partie de différentes
communautés et c'est à nous d'ouvrir les
esprits et le coeur des gens qui nous
entourent
parce que je vous le dis tout de suite
il n'y aura pas de files heure ou deux
moderna pour
indiquez le sexisme l'homophobie
l'islamophobie de nos sociétés un on est
à la fois le problème et la solution et
du coup j'en appelle à chaque personne
qui aurait été touché par ce discours
d'agir d'éduquer d'informer autour de
vous afin qu'il n'y ait plus jamais de
gamins comme moi qui se alice qui se
trahissent et qui ne seront jamais de
quoi il aurait été capable s'il avait
évolué dans les environnements plus
tolérant et inclusif et je terminerai en
vous disant que pouvoir être soi est un
droit dont personne ne devrait être
privé merci
[Applaudissements]